your time will come diana and everything
will be different
[Music]
what do you want to know about wonder
woman 1984
the answer is always more then take a
look behind the scenes with us
this long anticipated wonder woman
sequel has certainly kept fans waiting
giving us plenty of time to delve behind
the scenes and learn
all about the off-screen secrets wow
you're
so funny from filming techniques to the
relationships on set we're taking a
close look at wonder woman
1984. however what happened on this film
blew my mind 84 takes us back to the
aisle of themyscira
to see a young diana participating in
the amazonian olympics
these sequences were shot in imax it was
very important to me to shoot this on
film
i believe in it tremendously meaning
special cameras and film had to be used
it's a grueling process that requires a
240 pound
camera or 109 kilograms that uses spools
that only hold three minutes of film
reloading the film takes 20 minutes but
director patty jenkins
called the experience mind blowing
insisting that footage captured using
imax looks better than
any other format greatness is not what
you think
returning to the role of young diana is
lily aspel
lily born in 2007 received warm wishes
from patty jenkins on her 13th birthday
jenkins commemorated her special day
with kind words and photos from the set
of wonder woman 1984.
the director is very supportive of lily
taking any chance
to encourage and congratulate her like
when mattel released a barbie doll
modeled after her i can do it
just do your best in the olympics scene
lily does most of her own stunts
she trained for five months to prepare
for the role she still had to rely on a
stunt double for some of them since she
was only 10 years old at the time of
filming
i forgot to tell you what radar will
they will they shoot at us
speaking of stunts paddy jenkins looked
to 80s movies for inspiration for wonder
woman 1984's stunt
she wanted huge 80s style action
sequences with as many practical effects
and stunts as possible
she didn't want it to just look like an
80s movie she wanted to film it like an
80s movie
this put a lot of demand on the actors
but according to gal gadot who does
many of her own stunts in the movie says
the effort and injuries were worth it
they will never find us chris pine
returns to play the mysteriously
reappeared steve trevor
after the way patty gal and chris hit it
off in the first movie
gadot claimed she couldn't imagine doing
another one without him
by the way steve's fanny pack was his
idea and when asked he admitted to
keeping treats inside of it
that's just a trash can it's just a
trash can yeah yeah
the trio had such a strong camaraderie
that kristen wiig and pedro pascal were
actually nervous about walking into the
already established friendship dynamics
we were terrified but luckily
they ended up being able to fit in
immediately jenkins remarked that the
mood on set was so much fun that
it felt like i was making something with
my friends from high school
the fact that gal and patty were already
fans of the two probably helped
life is good but it can be better all
you need
is to want pedro pascal was actually
nervous about doing the movie
he was intimidated by the massive
success of the first wonder woman film
he was ultimately glad he accepted the
role of maxwell lorde
as evidenced by this fun breakfast club
inspired photo with the main cast and
director that he posted to instagram by
accident while trying to apply a filter
to it for personal use
lucky for him the photo didn't reveal
any closely guarded dcu secrets so he
didn't end up getting in any trouble
over it
no one's made me laugh like this in such
a long time kristen wiig and gal gadot
became the best of friends off camera
the two shared an
instant connection according to gal wig
usually a comedic actress was facing a
new challenge by taking the role of
barbara minerva
aka the cheetah we're sure she was glad
to have a friend like gal
who she called a great scene partner the
two were able to switch between their
off-screen friendship
and on-screen rivalry with ease gal and
i love
each other she's brilliant there were
plenty of on-set friendships blossoming
and not just between the actors and the
director gadot and jenkins both had
their families on set
their husbands and children have all
become close friends making wonder woman
1984 sound like one big
family behind the scenes the world of
wonder woman 1984
is one of excess the film features
iconic landmarks from the u.s capitol
like the washington monument and several
scenes were shot on location
all of pennsylvania avenue was shut down
to film one of the film's epic action
sequences
and there were scenes shot at the
watergate hotel and in front of the
national archives
they even constructed a fake commander
salamander in georgetown for
authenticity
this boutique was a staple of dc's
retail scene for 34 years before closing
shop in 2010
but the crew brought the storefront back
just for the film
we find diana in the wonderful vivid
super cool um
80s the entire production went to great
lengths to be faithful to the time
period
revlon provided makeup for the film even
reproducing the actual colors and shades
they ran during the 80s
jan seawell the makeup and hair designer
for wonder woman 1984
praised the quality of the products and
felt they were an important contribution
to the film's authenticity
you don't get out no i seem like the
kind of person who's like
always out one of the challenges they
faced was finding a balance between
staying true to the flashy fashion of
the 80s without having a wardrobe that
was too distracting
you look amazing i'll take it many of
the movies outfits were lifted right out
of the pages of magazines from the era
then altered to suit the film's needs
diana's white dress was inspired by a
dress from a dior fashion show in 1984
and one of her more casual ensembles was
taken from a 1986 ralph lauren ad
featuring brook shields parachute pants
yeah does everybody parachute the
costume designer for wonder woman 1984
is lindy heming who also worked on the
christopher nolan batman trilogy
diana's golden armor was designed to be
worn in pieces
allowing for easier filming less time
spent on costume changes and more
comfort for gal gadot
at the end of the day there's no two
ways about it gal is my
greatest creative partner on these films
director patty jenkins was conflicted on
how to release the film in the midst of
a pandemic
she felt it was important for people to
see wonder woman 1984 on the big screen
especially for the amazonian olympic
sequences shot in imax
there's a quality to immulsive print
filmmaking it's like the highest level
of
oil paint jenkins had been vocal in her
support of movie theaters saying
i don't think any of us want to live in
a world where the only option is to take
your kids to watch a movie in your own
living room
and not have a place to go for a date
jenkins was willing to compromise with a
simultaneous theatrical and home
streaming release
if you had told me a year ago that we
would ever go straight to streaming in
any way shape or form
i would have flipped out i'm very pro
theatrical release and i will be that
again
as soon as this is over however this is
such a crazy year
have you ever been in love a long long
time ago
did you learn anything new what's one of
your favorite behind-the-scenes stories
from a movie
let us know in the comments if you want
to learn more about wonder woman check
out our video on the evolution of wonder
woman on screen
if you love content like this make sure
you're subscribed and hit the like
button
you